Sengeh: Hundred percent of
people living with amputations
experience prosthetic
socket discomfort.
It's both a technology problem
and it's a science problem
because we don't really know
how to connect
the body to machines.
( applause )
There are ten million people
living with
amputations globally.
They could have gotten
those from accidents
victims of war
or diabetes.
They range from people
who are in the US
to people who are in my
home in Sierra Leone
to Cambodia,
all over the world.
But one thing is constant.
Hundred percent of them
experience prosthetic
socket discomfort.
That's a residual limb
with bones inside.
That is very different
for everybody.
The part that connects
that residual limb to the
prosthetic leg is uncomfortable.
And part of that is because
the way we conventionally
make prosthetic sockets today
is through an artisanal process
for an ever changing human body
that is so diverse
across the population
and across the whole world.
And the way prosthesis
prosthetic sockets are
designed today
is you go to a prosthetist
and they take your leg
and they squeeze your leg and
ask you, "How does that feel
if I press here a little
bit does it feel great?
What about that, what about
your patellar tendon?
What about this bone
that's there
is there a bone in there
I don't know?
How did this happen?"
You get the picture.
It is not repeatable.
It is based on the experience
of the prosthetist.
And the mold that is created is
based on somebody's experience.
You create and alter
that positive mold
you make a negative mold
and then you pour another
positive mold inside
and then you modify that, and
then you make a test socket
and then the person goes
into the test socket
they give you feedback,
like telling
"Oh, I don't think
it's comfortable here"
and then you modify it again
and then you do this
over and over and again.
Until you or the person goes
"Yeah, it's fine,
I can work in this".
( audience laughter )
And when you do get carbon fiber
sockets of single material
you have your residuum get
blisters and pressure sores.
If you look closely around
the fibular head there
you can see some blood spots.
It's both a technology problem
and it's a science problem
because we don't really know how
to connect the body to machines.
So, one of the things that I was
interested in with my boss was
how do you understand
the science
behind designing for comfort.
So, on the left is a fit-socket,
which is an array of indentors
in which the person
inserts their residuum
to capture experimental data of
force, displacement and time
so we can use it to characterize
the model of the person's body.
I decided that it was
perhaps useful to
link those points with a MRI,
so that we can
create models and we can
link the experimental data
to the modeling data directly.
So, we have these markers
that you can see in an MRI
and you segment that MRI,
so we define the bones
define the skin, define all
the other soft tissue.
And then we can create in
an exact replica, so we can
ask questions around design of
the interfaces we have.
And then we can build models
that is predictive,
and we can use these to now say
what happens inside the body.
How is the soft tissue
straining around the bone.
We can test all of these
now and go in and say
"Well, we don't need to make a
single material socket anymore.
We can now take your body with
all those markers that we put
and that model that we created
that was validated and
that's predictive
create an element
all across your body
with which we create the sockets
where each color
is a new material
and test this hypothesis.
Why does this all matter?
Why... why does understanding
the science of
how we connect the body
to machines matter?
Your shoes still
give you blisters.
If you know somebody
who has scoliosis
they hate wearing their brace.
If you have a knee or an ankle
injury, you hate your braces.
And that's because we don't know
how to connect the body
comfortably to machines.
And, the science behind
designing for comfort
really starts from being able to
merge these experimental
and numerical data
and build predictive models,
and ask questions around
how our design actually affects
the behavior of the body
as we use these machines in time
and across loads and
across different terrains.